hey Ryan you're on the air hey I you
tweeted something if I could just reread
it and then maybe get your take on it
you said the reality is life is a single
player game
you're born alone you're going to die
alone all of your interpretations are
alone
all your memories are alone you're gone
in three generations and nobody cares
before you showed up nobody cared it's
all single player I mean and I think
about this quite a bit myself I spend
quite a bit of time alone and sometimes
it has me thinking what's the point so I
was just wanted your your take on that
thanks yeah it's a good question okay so
life is a single player game obviously
it's not 100 True Life is also a
multiplayer game but I think it's more
interesting to consider it as a single
player game because that's not a thought
that gets brought up as often the
society always trains us for society's
ends and Society is a multi-user
organism so it will train us for the
multi-user game so only the individual
can themselves stumble upon the single
player game and that frame of mind and
see where it takes them so why is this
an interesting frame of mind firstly
there's a lot of truth to it so much of
the world so much of is your
interpretation of the world so much of
mindset is your mindset to a tree or a
rock or a house or even another person
reality is very different to an object
reality is neutral to another subject
reality is subjective from their point
of view so a lot of this is up to you
how you want to interpret it another
Point here is that the only moment that
really exists is now even tomorrow or
yesterday are just thoughts in the
current moment so nothing exists outside
of right now you're not necessarily
going to be around for any appreciable
period of time everything you do will be
forgotten like everything in the past
has been forgot it's not to say it's
meaningless but it's more to say that
you create your own meaning you
interpret your own meaning you you are
the meaning of your own life and that
gives a freedom now you can you're free
to interpret this however you want
inside every person is either a budding
God or a budding demon or an angel or a
saint it's entirely up to you how you
choose to interpret it I just recommend
that you interpret it in a way that is
as close to reality as possible because
then you're likely to make less mistakes
and if you have the choice if you must
choose then interpret it positively
because it's just better to live a
positive experience than a negative one
people who commit suicide for example
God bless them but they left the game
too early that they were going to leave
the game anyway everybody leaves the
game eventually so you may as well just
stick it around see what it has planned
for you why do anything is this a
problem is the problem if there's a lack
of meaning no it's a form of freedom if
there was a meaning to life then we
would all be stuck trying to figure out
that meaning and the moment that a
person found that meeting and shared
with everybody else then we would all be
enslaved to that particular meeting so I
think it's liberating that there's no
meaning to life you can create your own
meaning and certain meanings that you
create or interpret are far more
pleasant than others some of them can
lead you directly to a life of
contemplative Bliss some of them can
lead you straight to creativity some of
them can lead you to helping other
people I would argue that the meanings
that are the best to create and work on
are the ones that self-actualize you
against your natural talents the thing
that you enjoy doing that puts you in
flow that has some worthwhile benefit
either to yourself or to society and
doesn't cause extreme negative
repercussions for you in this life and
just be aware that a lot of the things
that look like they're good for you are
actually just good for you in the short
term and they do cause negative
repercussions so long term so to me the
part of the secret of living a good and
happy life is just understanding
long-term consequences of your actions
and so if you create a meaning that long
term will lead you to compound interest
in good relationships and in creating
wealth for yourself and not having a
very busy mind and just being able to go
through life sort of Happy from moment
to moment that's going to be a better
life that you've created for yourself
but yeah if you want to create a harsher
and darker or shorter life for yourself
you should feel free to make that choice
I just don't think it's a very wise
choice the single player game frame also
robs you of this idea of Outside Agency
it takes away this idea that you're a
victim that things happen to you that
you don't have agents in your life I
think that the belief that people fall
into where they're victims there are
real victims in real circumstances but
they're far rarer than Twitter what have
you believe on Twitter there's many
budding victims who are raising their
hand crying for victimhood and all
you're doing is you're robbing yourself
of your agency you're robbing yourself
of your ability to make a difference in
your own life so even if you have been a
real victim let's just go ahead and
accommodate that for a moment I would
say it's still a better frame to
basically say no life is a single player
game I choose to rise out of that I
choose to interpret that and long term
when you look back on your life the
moments you can be proudest of is when
you Rose past circumstances that were
difficult when you Rose past your
suffering and then you accomplish
something that's where character is
built that's where resumes are made
that's where people have their proudest
moments so if you had no adversity it
would be a really boring game imagine a
game of I don't know Mario Brothers
where there was no jumping and no prizes
and nothing to do and no monsters it
would be incredibly dull and Incredibly
boring also a game that went on forever
would get really dull so I would say
play the game it's your game you get to
design the board you just have a
challenge you get to design the victory
condition and that's a lot of the
creativity one of my other related
tweets is the only true test of
intelligence is if you get what you want
out of life and this one triggered a lot
of people which I love the tweets that I
trigger a lot of people but they're
undeniably true which is intelligence is
like this abstract concept that we talk
about but the real measure is did you
get what you wanted of life and these
are two parts in there it's not just one
part one part of course is were you able
to hack reality to get what you wanted
but the more important part is were you
smart enough to figure out what to want
in the first place and that means there
are many booby prizes that simply aren't
worth having and then there are others
that are out of your reach it's
ludicrous for me to desire wings or even
to travel into a rocket into outer space
because it's either low Roi effort or
it's unachievable for me so what I want
to do is to figure out what it is that
is worth wanting and remember not
wanting something is as good as having
it so if you cannot warn in the first
place that's even better but the test of
intelligence here is getting what you
want out of life but also knowing what
to want so when life is a single player
game you get to craft it it's a blank
canvas it's not a negative thing it's a
positive thing it gives you a level of
Freedom you would not have multiplayer
games are inherently less free single
player games are more free I encourage a
single player frame simply because
Society will not encourage it you won't
hunger it outside of the individual and
also because it gives you back your
agency and it has the benefit of being
largely true my takeaway is the
following framing your life as a single
player game to the extent that is
relevant has not only properties of
Truth on itself but it is also
supportive to one's life as it is
liberating and empowering
now I leave you with a selection of my
three favorite quotes on this matter
Society tames the wolf into a dog and
man is the most domesticated animal of
all nature between stimulus and response
there is a space in that space is our
power to choose our response in our
response lies our growth and our freedom
Victor Franco they lose the day in
expectation of the night and the night
in fear of the Town Seneca would you
like to get access to the finest nuggets
from the best non-fiction books out
there if you do you should check out
short form for disclosure short form is
not sponsoring this video but there is
an affiliate Link in the video
description why am I promoting short
form well my purpose through this
channel is to collect valuable insights
from videos of people that I deeply
admire now imagine if you can easily get
the most valuable insights from the best
non-fiction books this is what you can
find on short form a curated selection
of the best books and for each book you
can find a carefully crafted summary in
which all the book's relevant ideas are
analyzed this is why I absolutely love
to read on shortphone and would
recommend it to anyone as Charlie Monger
argues to have a good unsuccessful life
you have to create a mental model from
all the big ideas from all the big
disciplines and short film can be
extremely helpful for this matter as it
literally extracts all the big ideas
from the best non-fiction books helping
you to create this mental model in a
faster and more efficient way and with
these valuable ideas becoming second
nature to us over time I think we will
be able to build our best lives by
standing on the shoulders of giants asir
Isaac Newton would put it now the way I
personally read on short form is to pick
from my personal Library any book that
sparks my interest at that moment and
start reading it typically I will read
sometimes in the morning after waking up
sometimes at night before going to sleep
and many times I will do a short read on
the mobile phone app when for instance
I'm in a restaurant alone waiting for
the food or commuting somewhere I
created my personal Library by quickly
scan through all the books on short form
and for any book to make it on my
library it has not only to interest me
but it also must fulfill at least one of
two conditions one is that I already
know the author of the book from an
interview in some podcast or any other
source that I personally trust and the
other is that the book itself has been
publicly recommended by people who I
deeply admire if you are interested in
short form you can visit my special link
shortfarm.com picking nuggets or use the
link in the description below to receive
unlimited access for 5 days and a 20
discount on the annual subscription if
you do choose to keep going after the
end of your trial thanks for watching if
you enjoyed the greeting content in this
video you will love our newsletter where
you can get in your email all the
greeting content plus the latest things
that I've been pondering to subscribe
always for free find the link below in
the description
[Music]
foreign